China just scored yet another huge blow
against the U.S after China and Brazil
struck a deal to ditch the dollar China
is now getting Malaysia to do the same
China committed to bribing I mean
investing nearly 39 billion dollars in
Malaysia and with that investment
Malaysia is now talking to China about
creating an Asian monetary fund to
reduce Asia's dependence on the US
dollar there's no reason for Malaysia to
continue depending on the dollar the
Malaysian prime minister said this Asian
monetary fund would replace America's
international monetary fund or IMF see
the IMF is America's loan shark against
third world countries whenever a poor
country can't pay its Loans To America
the IMF would always break their legs
but now Malaysia doesn't want to take it
anymore which is why